hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft exit auf dem home server
gestern kamen gar kein video weil ich
bis viertel nach vier schule hatte dann
muss die nach hause fahren musste
duschen bei sport hatte und dann wurde
blut abgenommen und zwar hier an so
einer stelle sieht man wahrscheinlich
auch nicht dass wir da in dieser coole
da wo es halt immer ist also ich kann
man aber jetzt nicht so cool drehen da
ist das irgendwo das hat ein bisschen
gepiekst und dann hat halt nicht
wehgetan und ich will euch das allgäu
als erzähler jedenfalls war ich jetzt
eher als beziehungsweise jetzt gerade
ist es 19 40 und jetzt gedacht indem
lieber für morgen aufgemacht das ganze
tier ich als jetzt noch schnell gegen
die scheiß folge auf zudem die
wahrscheinlichkeit weise kurzweilig sohn
hektik bin und die dann wahrscheinlich
erst drei stunden später online kommt
also dann 20 vor elf heute haben dann
guckt sich das eh kein schwein mehr an
deswegen darf ich mache jetzt einfach so
eine verdammte fünf leute auf dem server
robot ok meine lieben freunde ich wäre
jetzt meine ganzen sachen sichern
werd mir nur mein schwert und meinen
augen nehmen und dann werde ich in die
stadt gehen und ohne scheiß ich sag
jetzt bevor die folge
ich sag das jetzt bevor ich auf den
server gehe ich gehe in den kampf und
ich werde einfach drauf gehen es ist mir
egal
also ich werde einfach so drauf gehen es
ist mir scheißegal ob ich sterbe oder ob
ich sachen verliere oder alles mögliche
ich meine es kommt halt ein neues
projekt und ich werde jetzt einfach noch
mal richtig richtig gas geben und
richtig viel spaß also das scheiße bauen
wer jetzt auf jeden fall angreifen und
so was
meine ich jetzt deswegen gehe ich jetzt
drauf und ich schau mal wer da ist ich
glaub statt gelb wird sagen die partys
und zander ja die porky zombie und congo
after man jetzt im flecka tierheim
verschenken egal ich gehe wahrscheinlich
sein
so jetzt helfe ich ihm die sachen die
piste ist voll
zu
spiegel pac man hier rein einen pfeil
eine goldene feder
dabei soll ich auf die video gehen
ich brauche die spiegel online ich kann
dabei einfach ein schöner brauch ich
aber so eine kacke eine schmelze okay so
ich will mir echt nicht sicher ob ich da
jetzt drauf gehen soll
ich bin mir da echt wo ich das schon
recht unsicher
so gehen wir denn hin
pink coffee and dieser relativ gut
ausgerüstet eigentlich müsste ich an
gelb gehen
ich bin mir da nicht so sicher ob ich
das wirklich drauf gehen soll
ich finde das irgendwie ein bisschen
kacke weil die mehrheit nichts getan
haben konflikte ich geh jetzt einfach
drauf es kann sogar sein dass jetzt auch
vom live haben
aber also voll mit leben aber ich habe
gesagt ich mache ohne folge also mache
ich ohne folge leute ich hab's euch
gesagt
nicht mehr verarschen
an die wilden blumen bringt
wir könnten die nicht hier in sein aber
damit es schön gemacht hiermit den
lämpchen und so
wenn ich ihr dann kurzzeitig mal so
schnell
in echter mit zögern aber schön aus die
haben auch schöne bäume hier ne und dich
bei eurosport statt blau das kann ich
immer so scheiße
das wäre ich kann ihn nicht rein lasst
es gebaut
ich kann da nicht rein ich komme da
nicht rein ich muss als irgendein
eingang finden das ist ja komplett
eingebaut da dann müsste auch noch
das auch nicht so viel drauf
auch hätte ich mir mal was zu fressen
mitgenommen alter auch noch verdammt
und jetzt kommen wir nie wieder zurück
scheiße ich muss mal was zu fressen
wollen bin ich scheiße waren die kacke
jetzt bin ich eben rein
nee
die pocken man das ist ein richtiges
psycho spielchen hier als wieder
warte mal ich bin doch an ich bin auch
gar nicht da rausgekommen ich bin ja
jetzt herausgekommen da irgendwo hier
war das
perfekt das ist geil seine spitzhacke
und ich das baby falsch abgebracht
nicht dass da wieder bei mir ist richtig
richtig psycho bekommen egal die sind da
beide
afag
2 gegen 1 ist aber kacke wenn schon will
ich eins gegen eins verlieren
oder so drei gegen drei das wär bestimmt
auch geil
darf ich mir denn gilt dass ich dennoch
eben was essen
mir egal
habe nur bock auf action
ok ich komme mal so dann komme ich jetzt
mal hin zu denen ganoven da war ganze
zeit statt gelb
so manfred jetzt noch eben was und dann
wird ein bisschen gefightet
das ist echt ne scheiße hier mit dieser
kann ich doch ne scheiße wird dieser
kacke ja ich will jetzt eine goldene
carrot ohne gold apfel und phoenix
kämpft noch mehr mit ich lese sich als
der dzv wohl jetzt lesen könnte
wahrscheinlich
ich sage euch jetzt nicht verlieren aber
nicht als erstes video negativ bewertet
nur weil ich verloren habe ich versteh
ich verstehe es nicht
eine komische verfügung
meine damen richtig wenig helm eine
türkin
nein verdammt schade aber egal ich finds
war ein geiler kampf ich habe jetzt
nicht daran gedacht dass ich irgendwie
trinken mitnehmen oder so dann hab ich
jetzt gar nicht gedacht scheiße wie soll
ich erstmal wieder beleben
dass ich alles zu ernst ach kaffee
trinkt habe ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht
ja noch gar nicht geredet einfach beim
kampf aber ich finde es war geil so mag
ich nämlich kein finde ich wenn einfach
viele leute dann auf allen gehen sowie
brothers und einfach nichts sagen
aber bei so was ist echt geil ich finds
echt cool wenn die mich jetzt auch
wieder beleben erlebt nicht wieder break
wieder
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich so ein scheiß
bett aber ich glaube nicht die
burgerkette westberlin nutze ich find es
war echt geiler kampf so macht das auch
spaß macht ihm spaß
jung cent will mich keiner wiederbeleben
von euch hallo
bild keiner machen
macht jetzt
ich schreib mal debitor bei skype
kurzzeitig glaube ich unter zehn leben
guter kam belebt mich mal spitze wieder
so nicht dass ich jetzt in diesem
scheiss todes screen eufor weile etwa
mit meinen grabstein hallo ich habe es
eigentlich nichts verloren also eine
goldene feder
das wars zwei goldene karotten aber
sonst nicht stimmt sonst nichts nee also
es war echt guter kampf hat spaß gemacht
war echt zwischenzeit ich dachte echt
nicht hätten chance weil ich ja
eigentlich nie so den wert darauf
gesetzt hätte jetzt meine ganzen sachen
zu verzaubern ich wollte eigentlich noch
mal machen wir wurden auch viele sachen
geschrieben zum beispiel tanz auf die
rüstung zu packen
damit die gegner schaden bekommen wenn
sie mich anschließen aber kurzzeitig was
echt gut da hatte ich glaube ich voll
leben also vor leben ist ja eigentlich
20 also ich hatte die roten verlief die
viel geld hatte ich nicht mehr ich hatte
voll rot also 20 und er irgendwie zählen
aber dann bin ich halt weggeflogen und
dann habe ich ihn unten her geboten
hatte er irgendwie mich mit seinem golf
schwert geschlagen was hat ihnen wie
mega viel schaden gemacht hat dabei
wollen die mich jetzt nicht
wiederbeleben
hallo
da
denn fällt echt scheiße ist denn hier
nicht irgendeiner grad irgendwie so ist
das cookies debitor zombie kann mich
einer vielleicht wenn der bündner bünde
fahrer es war ich fand es echt geil
ich fand den kampf gut ich hatte am
anfang ich gedacht ich kack direkt rein
vielleicht hat es doch extra gemacht
mich so ein bisschen aus gezögert kann
ja auch sein und ich bin mir nur ein
dass ich ein bisschen was geleistet
hätte aber nicht sonst hätte ich sollte
auf dem bogen klopp schon oder nicht
dass die jetzt hier
hallo meine damen und herren beste
lieben es weiter aufnehmen
hallo
ja es wird hier irgendwie nichts getan
hier wird nichts ja ich gehe jetzt
runter dass es nicht die haben mich
jetzt nicht wiederbelebt also ich weiß
nicht keine ahnung vielleicht vielleicht
haben sie es auch gemacht aber die haben
einige chat geschrieben kannst wieder
drin ist auch egal ich fand's gut ich
fand es war ein guter kampf und ich
würde einfach sagen mit euch gefallen
hat lassen bewertung da ich weiß die
hälfte wird wieder negativ sein rad
verloren du bist eine pussy
ich setze mein wert nicht so auf pvp
sachen in seinem projekt es ist auch
kein pvp projektes ist ein rpg projekt
das versteht hier niemand deswegen auch
hero exit role play role play rpgs and
he pvp guitar hero
das heißt miteinander handeln
miteinander spielen frieden schließen
und auch nicht immer kämpfen
man kann zum beispiel glaubt bei ihnen
dem spiel was möglich wegen der role
play alles ohne gewalt zu beenden
klingt zwar komisch märkten mag ich auch
nicht so aber ich habe ich darauf hätten
die wirklich spezialität deswegen bitte
lasst einfach eine bewertung da und
stimmten gegen die discs schreibt mir
die kommentare noch mal was sich alles
an verzauberung draufpacken soll was ihn
noch eventuell jetzt wurde hier zu ende
geht alles von mir sehen wollen nochmal
in dem projekt und dann will ich sagen
morgen kommt kein hero da kommt dann was
anderes wenn ich mir dann überlegen und
dann will ich sagen macht's gut einen
schönen tag und